you don't want to stay in one lane and  just go let's get this well I mean look  let's let's really answer Peter I think  the reason I'm not is because I want to  buy the New York Jets and when I turn 30  I mean this is the true I mean the real  reason is because I want to buy the New  York Jets and on my 30th birthday 10  years ago I was driving to Wine Library  I looked myself in the rearview mirror  and I said you are full of [ __ ] there's  nothing you're doing over the last five  years that is putting you anywhere close  to a physician to buy a billion-dollar  sports franchise so you miss her on this  glorious thirtieth day better decide if  that is actually what you want and if  not Mazel Tov go have a nice work-life  balance make some money do your thing  but right now on this day November 14  right 2005 I want you to decide what  you're doing and I looked back at that  angry version of myself and I said you  might want to buy the Jets